what how's it going reject nation my
name is John Humphrey and I know what
you're thinking you're thinking John
you're not Gregg well guess what guys
Gregory is out of town this week he's
going to a wedding in Colorado so for
that time y'all are stuck with me John
week is gonna be good alright this is it
nothing is gonna go wrong that I know of
yet and I thought what better way to
start off this nerve-wracking
responsibility by talking about to think
I am undoubtedly the biggest expert
about on this channel the Marvel
Cinematic Universe there's a new Thor
Ragnarok international trailer out I
just came across it on Joe Blow movie
trailers and hey let's not waste any
time let's get into this I'm excited
let's do this changing your diet plans
to you my
plans for destiny
[Music]
I've gotta the best to convey without
job
we'll be glad see
[Music]
mistake
reborn - we'll stop here now - thank you
I block the end of everything
[Applause]
to the collegiality
you baby
why
[Music]
I don't think you're so cool
[Music]
whoa
[Applause]
I'm not Korean
success
[Music]
what were you the goddamn again
oh no yo they're saying goodnight just a
couple of hotheaded for ages Oh
[Music]
oh boy okay so a lot of that a lot of
that stuff we've already seen but I you
know I feel like Cate Blanchett's gonna
rock this movie I'm saying you know like
hey hey someone's backing up a very loud
truck out oh this is great you guys it
feels just like normal I don't know what
I was so nervous but the first thing
that comes to my mind for whatever
reason when I'm watching this is just I
think Cate Blanchett is going to rock
this movie you know I mean say what you
will about Marvel's villains and and you
know their struggles with getting really
threatening and memorable villains with
you know motives they're more than just
ah y'all are bound down to me I'm gonna
destroy it all to be fair you know that
one that one moment where she says I'm
gonna reshape it in my image you know a
little concerned by that but the goddess
of death I feel like there's a ton of
potential in here and just the look of
this movie alone I mean the thing I keep
noticing from all these trailers is that
the Marvel movies look great but
Ragnarok seems to be really doubling
down on these slow motion almost like
tableau style shots I feel look like
paintings which i think is really
amazing mythological art you know
whenever you see paintings depicting you
know the stories of ancient legends and
things like that like that's what I'm
kind of reminded of but in a more
comic-book context I think that's really
cool and I mean the elephant in the room
here is Doctor Strange of course he's at
the top of this trailer shows up for a
couple of seconds I think that's pretty
sweet
I'm not a huge fan of constant
crossovers but I think Marvel is
smoothing out the way that they've been
doing it and Doctor Strange makes a lot
of sense to be in this movie you know
Doctor Strange is the more metaphysical
side of the Marvel Cinematic Universe as
of now one thing that does strike me
about this is if some of the previous
trailers have been more bands or heavy
more about the humor this one seems very
much geared toward the battle at hand it
does feel like a more action-oriented
trailer I like that we get a few more
shots of Valkyrie play by Tessa Thompson
fighting and just some of the creatures
and stuff like that I really like that
they are playing up and utilizing the
sort of mythological side of this
because it's worth or comes from Fenrir
showed up in an earlier trailer I
believe but just to see Hulk squaring
off to grabbing a jaws and stuff like
that like that's always a move that gets
me riled when that kind of a fight goes
down sort of low-key perhaps bestiality
is fun for nobody um there's a lot of
really cool looking set pieces here it
looks like an intense movie from this
trailer and that's where I become a
little bit conflicted because while this
is an important story for Thor Ragnarok
is Apocalypse that raises the stakes
immensely I am concerned that it doesn't
just devolve into another apocalypse
scenario just with different wallpaper
the thing about superhero movies is that
you know we see a lot of cities crumble
we see a lot of end of the world
scenarios and so all that I'm hoping for
is that they find a way for this movie
to make that unique beyond just the look
and feel of everything because that's
account most definitely but I do think
that they still have to bring their
a-game in terms of how they communicate
that you know it can't just be cool
action at this point you know I hear a
lot of people saying guardians of the
galaxy and I can definitely see that
influence more especially with the 80s
vibe and they're adding a bit more you
know laser beams I do hope that the team
they've assembled you know Hulk and
Valkyrie and Loki and Thor as it looks
like it's going to be here I'm sure some
of the other characters are going to
figure into I don't want that to become
just a different set of guardians if
that makes any sense of all the Marvel
franchises seems like the Thor series
needs to nail one because what I like
the first Thor a good amount and a lot
of people seem to Thor the dark world
kind of shaky reactions and so this
feels like the one they need to nail it
on and I feel like Ragnarok as the
stakes has all the potential for them to
be able to do that
it is another apocalypse scenario so I'm
a little cautious about that but that
being said I mean like the goddess of
deficit
and is the terrific choice for that you
know me I'm usually the less excited
about these kinds of movies on this
channel but thor ragnarok actually has
me really excited basically I feel like
it's on this movie to just really pack
it with the personality that's what it's
all going to come down to for me and I
think Taika Waititi and his crew have a
great grip on that so I have a lot of
faith in this movie I'm not without my
concerns but I do have a lot of faith in
this movie I think it's going to be cool
I'm looking forward to it what do you
guys think comment below share your
thoughts with us because we would like
to hear them you can subscribe to the
real rejects cook that so the sense of
them click that notification bell to get
updated every time a review or a video
is out I'm dead John Humphrey on Twitter
and Instagram also check us out on
patreon patreon comm slash the real
rejects we've got all kinds of fun perks
and things going on right there nice
little community sharing jokes back and
forth chat and getting to know each
other it's a lot of fun belts got
t-shirts available on spread shirts
shotgun Richard calm flash the real
rejects pimping all sorts of stuff much
love guys see you next time